one time i got [ __ ] like you know
harassed in school
and then my it was like a saturday
morning my dad comes to pick me up and
she's
my my mom's telling my dad like you know
your son keeps getting bullied he's like
well stop getting his hair cut at super
cut slid
he looks like a [ __ ] idiot stop
giving him number seven it's super cool
you know those kids at the [ __ ] lemon
tree getting number eight he's got a
mushroom ankle what do you think he
looks [ __ ]
that's why that's why when people are
always like um
people who grow up without dads have
such dad issues it's like yeah because
you don't get
i would have loved that yeah to been
like what are you doing trish this kid's
soft yeah instead my mom's like
it's all your fault and you should
probably think about it and you're like
yeah
cool i'm gonna have raging anxiety for
all the rest of my life yeah
no i remember one time do i was like ten
i i wanted to join like um like you know
the
actors club or whatever they were
calling it was like the actors or
theater the theater
a club that they had at my school and my
mom was like you know
she was on the phone with my dad and she
was like um and she was like what do you
think
about uh having chris do the actor's
club and i could you know hear him i was
right by the receiver
and he was like uh never gonna happen he
goes you're gonna have to kill me first
and then and then she like put her hand
over the phone she's like i'd love to
see that happen
let me tell you something about boys
that are raised by moms yeah we have a
sassy level
yeah most men don't have or like not
like to
when you're raised by a single mom and
they just like kind of you're like
you're their girlfriend that they dish
to sometimes where they're like
huh yeah well where was that in the
marriage
i know she told me i remember one time
my dad i was like
six years old to get on the phone and i
was like dad like what do you do what do
you do
like for a living or like something
about a job and my dad was like ah you
know
he was like uh right now you know i work
in accounting he's like but i was almost
as short stop for the
for the short stuff for the new york
yankees he's like i was almost the
shortstop for the new york yankees and i
was like wow that's so cool and my
because my mom was like on the phone but
i could hear it and my mom here she
put her hand to the receiver she's like
he never stood a chance
i'll never forget it she i'll never
forget her saying she never stood a
chance
men are brutal to women physically
yeah just throughout time men are brutal
to women physically just
with beating whatever it is like back to
caveman [ __ ] women
since the dawn of time have been brutal
to men emotionally oh my god
in a way where they can emotionally
bully you
in a way that a man will never be able
to you know they're just like he didn't
stand a chance
if your dad heard that now he'd be like
well hold on a goddamn second
i could turn two with the best of them
yeah i bare-handed a [ __ ]
yeah yeah even with my stepmom now like
i remember he once uh
when i met my kid's mom you know she's
pretty you know
latina puerto rican girl so introduce
it's my dad my stepmom introduced her to
my girl and she's like um
and then my dad's like you got a hot mom
for the old man and then my stepmother's
like ugh she's like hi
tony you're on dialysis do you think
that that's what a hot mom
would want even if she had out mommy you
think that's what she wants to show up
to your appointments every tuesday and
thursday
like i do you fat [ __ ] and then he was
like i'm gonna trade this one in for 225
year old she's like i'd love to see you
try
yeah she was just like oh yeah because
that's what it is when you're mad that
long it's just all honestly she's like
if you could trade me if you could get
125 year old she's like i'll gladly
leave i'll go to florida live in my
father's house
yeah dude i love that that's the kind of
honesty that you
need to [ __ ] survive thank you so
much for watching hope you enjoyed the
last video
don't forget to tell your friends like
subscribe and turn on notifications
[Music]